pink brings down the house at the 60th  annual Grammy Awards  [Music]  the singer took the stage at Madison  Square Garden in New York City on Sunday  and her usual  left the audience in awe  [Music]  the 38 year olds who often performs  while doing flips and spins suspended in  the air opted for a stripped-down  performance of her song wild hearts  can't be broken  leaving the glitzy costumes at home  instead rocking a white off-the-shoulder  t-shirt and baggy blue jeans  [Music]  and if Pink's insane vocals weren't  enough to give you all the fields  cameras panned to her hubby Carey Hart  and their six-year-old daughter Willa  who were in the crowd cheering her on  [Applause]  [Music]